what should you do if you want to start
a fashion design business we're going to
answer that question in today's episode
of lunch and earn so recently I asked a
question for one of my YouTube followers
kara love you guys who wrote in to say
hey Ivan my name is Kara I watch your
videos a lot and I was think about being
a fashion designer is there any advice
you can give me before starting my own
fashion business and can I get a shout
out on your next video please
Thanks so you wanted a shout out hey
Kara so what do you think I think
fashion is a really creative industry
and like a lot of creative industries
the type of people who want to get into
it are usually really into fashion
they're into design they're into you
know the sewing and the pins and needles
and the drawing and whatever else it is
I think if you were to jump into any
industry like that you need to be aware
of also the business side of things
so I think I think yes have a passion
for fashion
I like that passion high fashion there
you go have a passion for fashion you
start there but also what are you going
to you know what are you gonna do in
your business path how are you going to
run your business how you're going to
get things sold how you gonna get things
manufactured how you gonna get them made
is that through a website like maybe is
it through you know retail and in-store
well how do you get stuff in store and
like a lot of creative businesses
creative people go into it and they have
such Drive and such passion to create
but then there's a whole other business
side of things and and that can be scary
and daunting I think for a lot of people
cool yeah so I have a couple of
suggestions to add onto what was Mark
the saying first off I would go work for
somebody that you respect in the
industry I would go get a job and not
not at some big company but at a small
fashion house ten employees where you
can learn from their success and get
really close to the entrepreneur founder
so you can understand how the business
works because so many people start off
in the fashion business printing
t-shirts and making your own clothing
and I mean they don't go anywhere
because you know you don't know enough
you don't have enough experience in what
you're doing and so I would go find that
job to learn to make connections to get
paid to make mistakes to get paid to
understand how that industry works
I would also study more successful
entrepreneurs I would look at people
like Armani and people at Coco Chanel
and people that you look up to and look
at how they got started right not how
our money makes extra money now but how
to go from zero to one how'd he get his
first piece out and get noticed and I
think it'll give you some specific
strategies that you can use but then
also give you some motivation right like
oh our money started off from nothing
Calvin Klein start up from nothing so if
they could do it I could do it too
I found that super helpful for me when I
was starting my business and then I
would also as a third thing just start
on the side so while I'm at my job while
I'm learning while I'm all in success
from these big guys I would start
something on the side just as a way to
improve my skills and to start building
some momentum I wouldn't spend any money
I don't know what you're making in terms
of fashion but I would look for a
website that could do all of the
production for you I would I would go
with like a Spreadshirt comm or
something like that where you upload
your designs and you can promote it and
you can start getting the sense if
people like your designs or not if
they're starting to sell anything you
lose a big percentage of each deal that
comes in but there's a zero cost for you
and so you don't have a garage full of
t-shirts that never sell what would you
say for some titles are the big risks
because that wasn't the question but
what are the big risks that you go down
the path you get really excited you
start the business you know you're all
excited about fashion but the blind spot
is you don't see the stuff that's like
that you're missing what could be the
risks in that the biggest risk is having
a basement or garage full of inventory
that nobody ever buys right your your
first design is probably not gonna be
the one that hits and you don't know
enough to know that that's not going to
work and I see it constantly like people
and they over invest on the idea because
it's the greatest idea ever
and then whatever it is if I'm going to
start a YouTube channel and I buy the
most expensive lights and camera and
tripod and microphone and then I get
into and realize oh I don't actually
want to do this or I actually suck on
camera and I would rather be an editor
or something right you don't suck okay
well I suck at other things so it's that
part of that learning process and I hate
spending money until I'm making money so
I think the biggest risk in any business
starting up is that you over invest you
take your life savings and you put it
into something that doesn't work out
because you're going to make mistakes
you will make six it's normal that's
part of the process and so I would
invest in myself the education and the
experience before investing dollars into
what I'm doing so our question for you
today is let's all help Kara with this
if you are in any kind of manufacturing
or heavy
this where you have to put a lot of
money into having stuffed in boxes what
are the advice that you would give her I
like it leave in the comments below and
we'll join in the discussion thank you
guys so much for watching
continue to believe and we'll see you
soon Mark Jagger everybody in the house
I'm in his house actually